en juin dernier il poussait les portes
du prestigieux palais bourbon pour la
première fois un an plus tard il tente
de garder la tête froide fait j'ai pris
ça depuis le premier jour comme un lieu
de travail
et donc je me suis tout de suite
projetés dans un lieu de travail et pas
ne pas sentir ce poids je ressens
effectivement la responsabilité mais le
poids de l'histoire jeu
je vais occulter quelques passes
[Musique]
à 39 ans bazana dire qui fait partie de
cette nouvelle génération qui souhaite
transformer la politique vers des
pratiques plus pragmatique et moins
idéologique un entrepreneur devenu élu
de la nation
vous êtes venu vraiment spécialement
pour l'entreprise pour cet emploi effet
d'abord six mois à shanghai à lundi aux
circonscriptions en visite dans cette
entreprise mâconnaise le député est
comme un poisson dans l'eau
quelque chose qu'on aime bien que la
cérémonie d'esprit
en fait tous les développeurs supprime
gidding pics de charge ou encore
développement agile un jargon familier
pour lui l'été dernier il a fermé son
entreprise de formation pour se
consacrer entièrement à son mandat de
député sont passés de dirigeant est ici
un atout certain
forcément que ce que ce mais dès qu'il
ya des choses que je ressens que j'ai
déjà que j'ai déjà vécu une personne de
terrain qui est un regard neuf
ça peut faire avancer beaucoup plus vite
les choses qu'une personne qui peut-être
dans un sérail depuis très longtemps
direction ensuite sa permanence
parlementaire pour ce qu'il appelle les
états généraux de la vigne et du pain
son idée réunir chaque semaine les
professionnels du secteur viticole
autour d'une thématique l'atelier du
jour est consacré aux formations avec le
directeur du lycée de davayé au moins
dire après on a un panel de formations
qui sont des formations courtes type
taille de la vigne
l'objectif c'est d'avoir et ben je pense
les 70 80 % des choses qui pourront se
faire au niveau local juste le fait
d'avoir tout le monde réuni ce qui ne se
fait pas habituellement
et puis si on doit a réussi à aller
jusqu'à légiférer sur certaines choses
aujourd'hui on est au moment des états
généraux de l'alimentation de la
présentation de la loi qui va arriver
et ben pourquoi pas pouvoir amender la
loi sur certains sur certains points
pour nous ce qui est nouveau c'est de la
proche du terrain d'être d'être d'être
plus ou moins représentées et de pouvoir
discuter les choses franchement vous
avez l'impression que qu'avant c'était
moins le cas bah je pense qu'on était un
peu plus éloigné du terrain
avant la république en marche bazana
dire qu'il n'avait jamais adhéré à aucun
parti politique pour législatives de
2007 il est désigné pour représenter le
mouvement
il part à la conquête du siège du temps
alors par thomas thévenoud et au second
tour
il s'impose face au très expérimenté
maire de mâcon poussée par la vague
macro et sa promesse de renouveau
je pense que la politique n'est pas un
métier on se met on s'engage c'est pas
évident de s'engager quand on vient de
la société civile c'est au delà des
efforts c'est qu'on sait très bien que
les problématiques que ça peut engendrer
pour un chef d'entreprise on peut
l'imaginer quand il reviendra après dans
le monde dans le monde privé
aujourd'hui sa vie se partage entre le
travail en circonscription et celui à
l'assemblée le train du lundi soir pour
paris est déjà presque une routine
malgré son manque d'expérience dans la
fonction l'homme pense avoir trouvé ses
marques
c'est dur de se dire de juger je sais
pas si c'est à moi de
un mois de faire mais ce que je sais
c'est que je donne
au maximum tous les jours que
voilà que je compte ni mon papa du tout
mon temps et que j'ai toujours géré
quelque part là faut en fait je crois
vraiment ce qu'on fait en notre notre
projet aujourd'hui au niveau national on
voit quand même
que la france se redresse
les chiffres de la croissance de
l'emploi la baisse de la dette jeu très
importante
puis du concret aussi qu'on a pu avoir
sur le territoire nécessité judiciaire
ça fait dix ans qu'on attendait ça à
mâcon on a pu la voir mon travail était
là pour beaucoup une gendarmerie qui va
être construite il ya plein de projets
comme ça
bonjour bienvenue dans mon bureau
parisien
la chance d'avoir deux bureaux séparés
ce qui n'est pas le cas de tous les
députés sur paris je peux avoir c'est
ici que le parlementaire prépare le
travail législatif ses interventions
dans l'hémicycle ou en commission par
rapport aux communes nouvelles
je pense qu'il faudrait ajouter qu
aujourd'hui en fait c'est au delà en
fait des futures élections c'est aussi
les les communes qui hésitent
aujourd'hui a basculé sur les communes
nouvelles parce que peur de la
représentativité de leur commune
d'aujourd'hui pour demain s'agit d'un
outil très important pour les
collectivités
un travail mythos lumière lorsqu'il
abouti à une question orale au
gouvernement
cette situation est particulièrement
intolérable s'agissant de plateformes
taquet remis mbi qui paye en a pour
ridiculement bas en france alors que
votre pays et son deuxième marché dans
un contexte de défiance vis-à-vis des
politiques
des sites internet tentent d'évaluer
leur travail sur des critères
quantitatifs comme le taux de présence
le nombre de rédaction de rapports ou
d'amendements
le plus connu d'entre eux c'est le
classement du magazine capital
un classement peu flatteur pour les
députés la république en marche souvent
en queue de classement
benjamin dire que c'est classé 73e
elle fait ça n'a pas de sens ça n'a pas
de sens puisque on classe en place par
rapport à quoi quand les critères sont
pas les bons voulait classer quoi le
travail quand on aux affaires étrangères
je vous le dis depuis tout à l'heure les
lois ne passe pas par les affaires
étrangères on peut demander à certains
endroits mais les lois ne passe pas par
nous donc forcément on n'a pas le temps
de passage dans l'hémicycle qui permet à
certains d'avoir
d'avoir des points il faut savoir quand
même le petit jeu qui se faisait
notamment avec les anciens députés qui
vont faire une petite interjections
pendant pendant les questions au
gouvernement ou pendant un débat sur une
loi juste pour bien montrer qu'ils sont
dans l'hémicycle et à ce moment là ils
ont un point ce serait bien si c'est ça
le travail d'un député moi c'est pas
mieux rester discret et miser sur la
qualité de son travail pour exister
c'est le pari de ce jeune député mais
cela suffit-il dans les rues de mâcon
nous avons présenté au portrait parmi
ceux d'autres personnalités politiques
locales
jamais un dirks député république en
marche du mak ont bien joué à trouver sa
propre voie de connaître
non non je ne connais pas ça va jamais à
dire que c'est le député super difficile
de marquer clairement un territoire en
seulement une année après des décennies
d'alternance entre la gauche et la
droite traditionnelle
pour benjamin dire et les autres
nouveaux députés du parti des manuels
macron il reste quatre ans pour y
parvenir
[Musique]